[Music]
now that their stock is in pound town
another squid game is still two years
off and you have more choices than ever
when it comes to background noise i mean
streaming services the only show keeping
netflix alive has returned i think you
should leave i don't know what to tell
you bud we're just shooting funerals and
showing the ones where the bodies fly
out
also stranger things it's still pretty
popular
there's only one more season until
stranger things is over and one more
year until these kids can legally drink
now the duffers are serving up 13 more
hours of 80s reference stew fast times
at ridgemont high choo choo chong's next
movie 16 candles teen wolf and romancing
the stone but since they're almost out
of stephen king to crib from
almost
they're tapping brand new sources of
nostalgia like heavy metal album covers
famous 90s movies and in some real snake
eating its own butthole moments early
seasons of stranger things
[Music]
stranger things i i liked that show when
i was a kid
goonies never say die and stranger
things took that to heart last night we
couldn't even take one group picture
because there was like 50 of us i was
like you need to start killing people
they just need to have one massacre
scene as always there's millie bobby
brown's 11 who's still getting more nose
weights than a horny anime guy
watch her get bullied at regular school
and xavier's academy for gifted
youngsters putting the young actress
through more pain and abuse than the
time she went on hot ones my face
doesn't feel like my face
then catch up with mike will jonathan
and an enchanted bong who came to life
that's a funny word man
for an indie road trip dramedy about
that unforgettable spring where you
realize you're gay in the back of a van
plus there's lucas and max he's
pretending not to be a nerd while we're
pretending an 80s trailer park kid likes
kate bush more than skynyrd
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and don't forget dustin steve erica
robin nancy blossom jughead and guild or
this exposition gang is here to speed
run us through all the nerdy lore of the
upside down so if the demogorgon was
just his foot soldier that was his
five-star general while protecting an
absolute legend named eddie munson this
metalhead with a heart of gold must stay
one step ahead of a terrible curse being
a fan favorite newcomer on stranger
things
dang it again justice for eddie
you too chrissy you too newspaper twerp
you too other bully
had enough characters well too bad
because most of the adults are still
alive too and they're slogging through
cuttable plotlines like my two lab dads
you don't understand what he's capable
of this is not our choice whether she
wants to stay or go right doc
the great russian trope off yes
and joyce and murray's epic side quest
to bring back chief hopper i'm gonna die
someday
but not today a character who should be
dead but someone wanted to watch david
harbor get tortured
like a lot
[Music]
stop stop stop he wasn't that bad in the
hellboy remake let's seal it with a kiss
okay just one more die
[Music]
but hopper is not the only lumbering
unkillable bald monster
there's vecna a psychic with the wettest
tentacles you've ever seen squelch
after 11 send him to the upside down and
burn his dick off skeletor's cousin who
had too much work done is back for
revenge and he'll get it in a five step
seven day long process for killing one
kid that feels pretty inefficient for
america these days
i'll throw on 20 rounds buckshot for you
but it's the first high we've seen an
even match up for 11 as long as you
overlook his only two weaknesses
music and friendship no
they're using the body system
it burns
so get ready for more cozy benchable
comfort food that you would have stopped
watching years ago if it weren't for
your parasocial relationship with the
cast as netflix beg you to stick with
them through their awkward phase you're
grown
yeah
and if we keep our subscriptions until
the next earnings report they can
pretend it's 2020 again
come on guys stick around it's just 10
to 20 bucks a month even cheaper once we
feel full of that
don't you want to know if this is cake
no
you'll be back for season five
starring
take this l
how many fins could a wolfhard wolf if a
thin wolf could wolf hard you can't put
that haircut on a grown man it's cruel
dusty the clown cliques and geeks
stephen king nan helsing
this one time at band camp buyers
remorse
my only regret is that i have bone itis
two years away from starring in
beetlejuice get to the hopper
this is what happens when you pirate
metallica kids nina papa always gets
paid
fenty
like wow scoob yak win the ussr
and the duffer brothers one rule for
their core characters everything works
out happy ending for everybody
epic real time
okay i'll just say it jason had every
reason to think the last person seen
alive with his dead girlfriend a drug
dealer who went into hiding was the
murderer but hey kind of half are not
being caught up on the lure sure
i piggybacked from a pizza dough freezer
help i've been eaten by john bailey
if it's too loud you're too old
i've been waiting ten years for a
comment like this
there's four seconds left in the video
enough time for one more quote